[Musique]
bonjour les amis
nous sommes très contents aujourd'hui
petit louis est guéri gros ours descend
vite le voir à tout à leurs patrons eux
peu lors pourquoi mais ne tarde pas trop
à revenir au repos bon on propose le
genre
alors comment se porte le monsieur aux
régions pauvres
j'ai préparé un beau bébé
je ne sais pas si j'ose seront bons elle
reste une fois que j aime bien les mêmes
dogmes bas et qu'est ce qu'il y a de
bons beaucoup de bonnes choses
il y à du chocolat chaud
[Musique]
mais attention il ya aussi des gâteaux
des brillants lol lol nan à amiens au
propos ce boss chocolat maaf et oui même
si je prends un brouillage mais certains
oui oui mais je voudrais rappeler la ta
sera le bon c'est vraiment délicieux
[Musique]
mets ta serviette que tu es s'annonce t
plaque sera partout maintenant
maintenant je continue
ou c'est trop beaucoup trop bon pour moi
j'ai plus un jeunot qui mangent et
gâteaux
oui alors qu' à manger le gâteau c'est
pourquoi moi ton petit peu seulement tu
peux te cacher la ville
ça c'est pas bon on m'aurait bien manger
moi aussi ça fait rien au front la
prochaine fois je te ferai quelque chose
de meilleur encore mois des spaghettis
[Musique]
le contenu mal au coeur c'est bien faire
oui les courbes en sont toujours punis
allons les enfants aller vite au dodo
moi il faut que je me sauve ils disent
m'attend au revoir qui coiffe
[Musique]
ouais
demain les petits enfants mais ne soyez
jamais aussi gourmand que peut-il oui
car vous risqueriez d'être malade ou
ceux de bon ce tabou et oui oui c'était
bon mais suite à moustache on tu as
l'air malin avec cette serviette de pb
vouthon museau tousalon mu patron way
bonnet mirebel bonnet petit louis bony
les enfants aller vite au lit et faites
de beaux rêves
à demain
oh
[Musique]